c'est quand même un endroit symbolique
de la République il s'est passé
tellement d'événements historiques ici
que de d'avoir l'honneur d'y siéger
c'est c'est oui c'est c'est très très
émouvant et
ou très émouvant et c'est beaucoup
d'honneur beaucoup d'honneur que que nos
concitoyens nous font lorsqu'ils nous
ils nous élisent pour être au Palais
Bourbon
premier pas dans l'hémicycle pour ce
parlementaire des Yvelines suppléant de
Benoît amont dans la 11e circonscription
Jean-Philippe met élu à boisarcy est
devenu député pour la première fois
quand ce dernier a été nommé ministre du
gouvernement
héros le Palais Bourbon et autour il y a
y a plusieurs plusieurs immeuble le plus
récent c'est le 3 rue arestin Brant avec
plusieurs députés qui qui sont qui sont
ici leur bureau ici moi j'ai le bureau
qui était à à jeanlavani jeanlavani qui
est député des Hautes Pyrénées et qui
était l'ancien chef de cabinet de de
François
miteran voilà le bureau du du député on
m'a remis une écharpe j'ai une cocarde
également que je dois installer dans
dans ma voiture et puis j'ai également
une carte d'identité de de député voilà
avec un un laisser
passer
pour rentrer dans dans les différents
bâtiments de de l'Assemblée nationale
puisqu'on ne rentre
pas à l'Assemblée nationale et dans les
les bureaux et les bâtiments de
l'Assemblée nationale sans sans laisser
passer voilà un bureau qui l'occupera 3
jours par semaine les lundis et
vendredis il sera à sa permanence à
trappe affecté à la commission des
affaires culturelles et de l'éducation
Jean-Philippe my souhaite défendre la
sensibilité politique initiée par Benoît
Hamont un monde d'avance vous verrez au
cours du mois qui au cours du mois qui
vient un débat en particulier qui alors
dans la loyauté totale la fidélité
totale à l'action menée par par François
Hollande et le gouvernement mais vous
entendrez une une certaine sensibilité
qui sera qui
sera mise en avant sur sur l'Europe en
particulier mardi 11 septembre une
session extraordinaire sonnera la
rentrée parlementaire premier projet de
loi à débattre les emplois d'avenir
proposition phare de François Hollande
lors de sa
campagne